i don't wear these clothes these clothes
wear me
i didn't move here to be a country style
sometimes things just happen they have a
saying down here called bless your heart
which you can basically say whatever you
want to somebody
and then just follow bless your heart
and you're fine that baby has a huge
head bless
her heart you've got to eat hot chicken
at hattie b
yeah there's a little bit of sweat near
my taint
got beer and country
this feels like it's in my soul buddy do
you think those pants fit bless your
heart i can't even notice
if it's at all hot i've actually started
my own look here it's called the
nashville mullet
business up top but i'm partying on the
bottom you don't grill
it it's all about smoked meat hey marley
dude only smokes is made for like 10
hours what
you can come have some of my smoked meat
or i can take you out on the biggest
tour you've ever been on
i think i'm gonna start going sleeveless
it's more comfortable
this is very kenny chesney i've been
smoking this pork
for 10 days it's gonna be the best
nobody can out smoke my meat people here
are so friendly everyone says hello to
everybody i like saying hi
here it's not the heat it's humidity but
i got to tell you i like it it's
thick it's like breathing applesauce i
say hi to everybody
friendly and by the way if i miss you
i'll find you
you know you're a country star they do a
lot of but when you're sleeveless you
got to point
people thank you oh i miss somebody
gotta say hi not my neighborhood
it's the nashville way if you're not
smoking your food what are you doing
smoked lettuce is so good i smoked
cucumber
boom maybe you spell y'all y a
apostrophe
ll yellow but i was told it's y
apostrophe a-l-l
i don't wanna come in and change things
around right away on day one but
eventually i think we're gonna switch it
over i don't know people say you get
heavy in nashville you don't
because the air is so heavy if you just
walk outside for a little while and
breathe you're full
i don't need to eat if i get hungry i
just walk around the block go go i eat
some apple sauce
i come back inside i'm full i haven't
actually changed
people have changed around me
i got a snickers bar in my smoker you
want a little piece of the smoke
sneakers
let's say something else people are
complaining about is the mosquitoes i
am immune to the mosquitoes all those
bats are at parties
and they got those weird dongs on their
heads
i think i nailed it i haven't had one
mosquito bite since i've been here you
know why
it's all in your brain if you don't want
the mosquitoes to bite you you know what
they're not gonna bite you they're all
out there yeah we're so crazy
we drink every time we hear one of them
go
oh that's swelling up pretty good
yeah i'll take some of that i'll take
some of that bug spray if you want what
what is going on they're on those pedal
taverns i saw one group of girls throw
up and keep pedaling i got to tell you
i actually respected that i chased them
down and said hello to him do i feel
comfortable in this most days yeah would
i
like some crops and some animals of
course
but i'm not a cowboy